jd you must have been filled with uh
tremendous anxiety knowing that you were
going to be going on a plane with john
and he was going to try to commandeer
the plane's microphone and make a
proposal to you as soon as we got to the
gate i'm just like standing there you
know we're waiting to get on and he's
walking away from me and like i try to
have eyes on him whenever i was in the
aisle seat he was in the middle seat and
every time he got up i knew something
was happening i would always straddle
him like romantically as when i tried to
get out of the seat now you had this all
planned out john this idea of making a
proposal to jd to be your husband
because even the night before when you
were at the japanese restaurant at the
end of the night you took a picture of
yourself kissing jd yeah you could show
it to the flight attendant so that you
would see you were a real couple like i
thought we were just joking around or
you know i was half drunk and you know
or full drunk and i thought we were just
taking a funny picture and i didn't
realize it was part of the whole [ __ ]
master plan of his i showed the flight
attendants the picture and i asked and
they're like oh my god that's so sweet
you know we've been working for the
airline for so many years and we've
never been part of a mid-air proposal
there's everyone was so excited and so
sweet about it how long does it take you
to convince the flight attendant to uh
let you commandeer the speaker in two
seconds they were like oh my god yes
let's do talk to us a couple hours into
the flight i went back and they're like
asking me to show me like show me where
jd is and i point to the seat they're
like okay okay we have the balloons
ready we have the confetti and they made
a nice little card saying
congratulations from the crew
jd what is going through your mind as
he's proposing i'm just like trying to
ignore it i just was just like let me
find something on the tv let me just see
what's going on on the tv here the
flight attendant was tapping jd and he
was like i know i know again
i know what's going on i know i know
what he's doing all right here he is
here's john blake proposing to jd um oh
so i'm here on a flight with my
boyfriend jd
and he's changed my life tremendously i
love him so much the first time he met
him fire and ice i knew that i'd want to
be with him for the rest of his life and
my life i remember the first time i
tasted him i remember the person i met
his family david they've accepted me
my parents accepted you
jd
jd i love you will you marry me jd
will you be my husband
i know i know sir whatever get out of jd
yes we go all right please come out here
so john is saying i love you won't you
please come up here and you're like no
no no no
the crowd starts cheering you on
everyone is just staring at me like it's
just everyone has turned their seats and
looking at me and i'm like i gave him
thumbs up and i just get get back here
just get back here
happy man
yes
[Music]
[Music]
thank you you stood up a little bit yeah
because i wanted to get it over with and
somehow
and then the whole airplane applauded
for john and j.d yeah
thank you
[Music]
thank you
thank you so much
thank you oh thank god thanks i love you
thank you [ __ ] idiot thank you very
much i love you
don't you champagne no i don't watch
champagne
i love you
thank you
oh what the [ __ ] is this thank you very
much
get this [ __ ] mic off me
did they throw confetti all over oh oh
they oh my robin this woman so he does a
proposal he sits his ass down a few
minutes later she comes up and she just
throws [ __ ] all over me jd one more
thing congratulations here's a little
treat
thank you congratulations
and we still have like two hours on this
flight i'm like what the [ __ ] come on
man are you [ __ ] kidding me so they
walked over to jd and dumped a whole
bunch of paper napkins all over them
yeah it was like rick taylor coming over
i did seltzer they sprayed you
and then they gave us prosecco and i i i
wouldn't even drink it on the plane
everybody took them off oh my god that
was a gift to me and your wife that was
a gift thank you you're welcome when you
guys land and you guys you know you're
leaving the plane
are people still congratulating you yeah
yeah oh yeah there was a rabbi on the
plane he was like mazel tov mazel tov
congratulations
i mean going to the super bowl is a once
in a lifetime experience was it worth it
having to put up with blit and all
nonsense well i would have been a lot
more work that the bengals had won i
mean what am i gonna do i'm [ __ ]
dealing with a maniac
you